TRUMPLAND, HIS NEW MOVIE, AND
NOW HERE YOU ARE.
WE HAVE LOTS TO TALK ABOUT.
IF WE LOOK AT THOSE PICTURES,
YOU JOINED ONE IN NEW YORK.
HOW DID IT FEEL TO BE THERE?
>> IT FELT GREAT AND THE
RANDOMNESS OF IT BECAUSE I
LITERALLY WAS JUST ON MY WAY TO
GO SPEAK AT A DOCUMENTARY
MEETING AND I GOT OUT OF THE CAB
AND ALL THE SUDDEN A WAVE OF
HUMANITY LITERALLY THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE COMING DOWN THE STREET
AND I -- I JUST JOINED THEM.
>> THERE YOU ARE RIGHT THERE.
>> OH, GEEZ.
>> WHAT ARE YOU DOING AND
SAYING?
>> I'M JUST SAYING -- ACTUALLY I
DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING.
I LET THEM TALK.
THERE WERE SO MANY THOUSANDS.
I ASKED THEM HOW MANY THEY
THOUGHT WERE THERE.
THEY SAID ABOUT T10,000.
I COULDN'T TELL.
>> WHAT ARE THEY SAYING?
>> THEY ARE SCARED FOR THEIR
FUTURE.
THESE KIDS, SOME OF THE HISPANIC
KIDS, THEY'RE IN THE DACA
PROGRAM, THEY -- THEY'RE WORRIED
ABOUT BEING TAKEN OUT OF THE
COUNTRY.
IT'S REALLY -- THERE'S A LOT OF
FEAR AND A LOT OF PANIC AMONGST
A LOT OF PEOPLE RIGHT NOW.
>> I'VE BEEN TRYING TO EXPLAIN
THAT AND NOT TO TAKING ANY AWAY
FROM DONALD TRUMP'S VICTORY, BUT
THERE'S SO MUCH FEAR AND THIS
ISN'T THE NORMAL FEAR.
>> NO.
>> WE'RE OLD ENOUGH TO REMEMBER
WHEN REAGAN WAS ELECTED AND
PEOPLE WERE LIKE OH, MY GOSH.
LIBERALS WERE LIKE JUST BESIDES
THEMSELVES.
>> IT WAS A DIFFERENT BESIDE
THIS IS COMPLETELY DIFFERENT AND
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO QUALIFY IT.
IT'S -- WHAT'S SCAREY IS, IS
YOU'VE GOT 77% OF THE COUNTRY'S
EITHER WOMEN, PEOPLE OF COLOR,
OR YOUNG DATES FROM 18 TO 75.
THAT'S 77% OF THE COUNTRY.
SO YOU HAVE A MINORITY, A MAN, A
WHITE MAN, OVER THE AGE OF 35,
SOMEBODY WHO REPRESENTS THE
MINORITY OF THE COUNTRY, IS NOW
IN CHARGE AND HE HAS SAID
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE CAMPAIGN,
HE'S SCREAMED INTO THE
MICROPHONES, I'M GOING TO DEPORT
TWO MILLION OF YOU, WE'LL START
WITH THE CRIMINALS, THE TWO
MILLION IN THE FIRST COUPLE
WEEKS.
I THINK THEY'RE -- I THINK
THEY'RE JUSTIFIABLY SCARED AND
MAYBE IF YOU'RE NOT OF THAT
GROUP YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT;
BUT I HEARD IT OUT THERE IN THE
STREET AND IT WAS INTENSE.
I WAS VERY PROUD OF THE FACT SO
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE CAME OUT
BECAUSE HIS PRESIDENCY HAS TO BE
OPPOSED RIGHT NOW.
HIS PRESIDENCY STARTED TWO DAYS
AGO.
THAT'S THE ATTITUDE PEOPLE HAVE
TO HAVE.
I MEAN, YOU REMEMBER THE
REPUBLICANS WERE READY TO START
THE IMPEACHMENT HEARINGS ON DAY
ONE AGAINST HILLARY CLINTON.
>> RIGHT.
>> ALL RIGHT?
THE -- THE OTHER SIDE NEEDS TO
BE READY TO ROLL RIGHT NOW TO DO
WHATEVER NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
STOP HIS APPOINTMENT.
>> IS THAT RIGHT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
YOU HAVE TO DO IT.
YOU HAVE DO IT ONLY BECAUSE -- I
APPRECIATE WHAT PRESIDENT OBAMA
SAID TODAY.
WE LIKE TO SEE THAT.
>> SUCH A CLASSIC FAMILY.
>> YES, THAT'S RIGHT, AND YOU
KNOW IT'S LIKE YOU WATCH THAT
AND YOU GO THAT'S THE COUNTRY I
WANT TO LIVE IN AND I THOUGHT,
TOO, THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA AND
HILLARY WERE GIVING A TUTORIAL
TO DONALD TRUMP SAYING, YOU KNOW
IF WE HAD WON, THIS IS HOW WE
WOULD HAVE WANTED YOU TO BEHAVE,
WH